hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
con la ley migratoria en chile el
ingreso al país para los migrantes pasa
por más controles militares y policías
se resguardan los puntos fronterizos de
mayor flujo uno de ellos el que une a
bolivia y chile entre pisiga y colchani
esta última una ciudad de epicentro de
manifestaciones por la llegada de
extranjeros la mayoría venezolanos la
norma permite la reconducción inmediata
a bolivia por ejemplo de los que
ingresan a chile de forma irregular pero
pese a las estrictas medidas y los
peligros del paso los venezolanos siguen
llegando veamos más en el siguiente
informe
5000 kilómetros hasta este lugar de
venezuela a bolivia pero con destino
chile
esto es pisiga una región boliviana que
limita con colchones desde aquí estos
migrantes están a un paso del que llaman
el sueño chileno
ilegal
vamos a hacer seguir porque
muchos familiares de nosotros y bueno
una mejor oportunidad que venezuela en
este punto una zanja los separa del
último país en su lista de viaje el sol
abrasador del día contrasta con el frío
de las noches en una ciudad ubicada a
3700 metros de altitud sobre y me espera
poder cruzar con sus hijos lo más pronto
posible mientras tanto la hermana
elizabeth ortega los recibe en este
albergue
no es
demasiado
te falta mucho la respiración
la gripe las niñas o sea es muy feo la
continua llegada de los migrantes llevo
a un grupo de religiosas a abrir las
puertas de esta casa para brindar abrigo
a los caminantes
como ya están a un paso se puede decir
de chile entonces no quieren volver
tienen que tienen que hacer este este
caminar para chile aunque pese a que
todo lo que le decimos que también
llegan otros que vuelven y les cuentan
la realidad que se han vivido pese a eso
ellos quieren arriesgarse y quieren
pasar para el otro lado
el paso aunque corto en distancia es
bastante peligroso la zanja que sirve de
límite tiene además una fosa de un metro
y medio cinco personas han muerto este
año al intentar cruzar por esta región
pero al final volver no está entre sus
planes
pudimos pasar colombia-ecuador y pasamos
perú a pie porque no pasaba y estamos
pasando bolivia porque no vas a chile
porque no llega a chile que nos impide
ante los peligros del cruce la opción
que muchos toman es pagar a traficantes
que les cobran hasta 100 dólares aunque
corren el riesgo de que los abandonen en
el camino
pero cuál es la situación hoy de los que
emigraron hace años algunos en chiles se
plantean volver a venezuela su retorno
está impulsado por el cansancio la
soledad y la falta de oportunidades los
testimonios de dos de ellos en el
siguiente informe
víctor deja su casa todos los días y
sube a su motocicleta que es un medio de
transporte y de trabajo en valparaíso
pudo emplearse como repartidor pero dice
que ya es hora de volver a venezuela
lo que se iba a hacer en chile ya se
hizo ya pasaron cinco años desde que yo
salí en mi país y ya está bueno ya está
bueno ya es hora de volver atrás la mata
la familia por muchos amigos muchos
amigos que tú conozca aquí gente que te
trate bien y todos los tuyos te llaman
siempre siempre las noticias de que la
economía está recuperándose en su país
natal lo impulsan a regresar incluso ha
tomado algunas decisiones para no llegar
con las manos vacías
y yo desde aquí hice
preparativos para volver a venir a la
palma compró una moto en venezuela monté
un negocio con mi papá
hay oportunidades allí hay opciones que
se pueden trabajar en venezuela una
decisión que ya tomó hace algunos meses
después de haber migrado a perú data de
tres años para poder venir mes
y no me arrepiento para nada de hecho no
quiero volver a salir los volvió a su
trabajo como manicurista y lo que gana
le alcanza
porque ahora está totalmente estoy mis
gastos tanto de alimentación como de
agua internet privado sin problema e
incluso uno que otros locos y también
estaba comprar unos artículos para mi
casa o sea todo ha sido paciente pero si
se logra y asegura que la venezuela de
antes no es la misma de ahora
no pensé que quería encontrar nuevamente
supermercados llenos porque cuando
percibí eso no existía lo que uno verá
que les hacía y me impactó ver la
cantidad de productos nuevos que tienes
para escoger ahora
los que retornan dicen haber tenido
malas experiencias y discriminación en
su periplo por lo que volver a su casa
es lo mejor para ellos
en total más de 6 millones de
venezolanos salieron de su país en busca
de mejores condiciones de vida pero los
datos sobre cuántos retornaron no son
claros lo cierto es que la pandemia
impulsó a muchos a volver a su país y el
dato de migración de la semana el relato
de una madre venezolana que tuvo que
huir de venezuela y el reencuentro con
sus hijos en ecuador es la historia de
por mis hijos un corto animado que
reconoce a las madres forzadas a
desplazarse
los traían en una camioneta
fue el reencuentro más emotivo de mi
vida
abrazarnos fue como
cómo volver a nacer
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]